the Vietnam War is for many an accurate
microcosm of the Cold War both the
communist north and the not communist
South had the backing of the two
ideological superpowers of the time the
South Vietnamese in the u.s. were joined
by soldiers from South Korea Australia
and New Zealand
but in this war there is one notable
absence Britain for what it's worth you
should know that the american president
lyndon b johnson did try to persuade the
British Prime Minister Harold Wilson to
send combat troops to Vietnam the reason
was to give extra legitimacy to the
mission there and Thompson even offered
financial support if Britain aided the
war there in the worth of Johnson's
National Security Adviser
a British Brigade in Vietnam would be
worth a billion dollars irrespective
prime minister Wilson was pretty clear
with his response no now you should know
that this promise of economic aid would
have been extremely tempting for Britain
since to put it mildly the economy
wasn't doing too well
the pound used to crash fairly reliably
in America's offer to prop it up would
have been extremely beneficial to
Britain's economy in fact it was
Britain's lack of money that led to it
reassessing what is called its role east
of Suez which is basically whether or
not Britain could afford to keep a
permanent military presence in Asia the
British economy continued to be plagued
with problems throughout the period of
the Vietnam War during which America's
diplomats would often hit this
possibility of economic aid for troop
deployments does this mean that Britain
gave zero support whatsoever no Wilson
made public his support at the u.s.
attempt to stop the spread of communism
in Southeast Asia also under US pressure
he made sure to dissuade other members
of government from criticizing the
United States publicly the thing was
that Britain couldn't commit troops to
Vietnam because the war was amongst the
British public seen at best someone
else's problem and at worse a war of
aggression beyond this Britain also very
early in the war sent a team of advisers
to help train the US Army and how to do
with guerrilla warfare this advice was
promptly ignored Britain's lukewarm
approach to the Vietnam War didn't do
much to help us British relations which
were made even worse by the fact that
Wilson and Johnson disliked each other
on a personal level between 1965 and
1968 US UK relations reached a new low
not like 1776 low but the two weren't
exactly best of friends either
for example when Wilson tried to advise
Johnson and what to do next Johnson
promptly told him to send troops or shut
up over the course of the Vietnam War
Britain would never send direct military
aid which is why it holds such little
place in British public consciousness
there was never really
much chance for British forces to be
sent to Vietnam this was mostly due to a
combination of public dislike for the
war alongside Britain's financial
struggles couple this with the
colonization and Britain largely not
knowing what its future role in the
world was going to be and it's not
surprising that it chose to sit this one
out and ultimately very few people
regret Britain not taking part in the
war I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show and a particularly
special thanks to James Bissonnette
party-boy Co kazarka flash Rob
Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael Reynolds
Thomas McGill Gustav Swan Winston
Hayward Skye Chappell the amusement park
Ives Adam Harvey and lastly rafail